i have a statement here in yellow which
for the sake of this video we will
assume is true that eating spinach
makes you stronger
and then after this in white i've
written a bunch of other statements and
i want to figure out if these are
reasonable things to say
given the assumption that this first
statement is true that eating spinach
makes you stronger and we can even put
it over here eating spinach eating
spinach
makes you
makes you stronger
so let's read this first sentence
if you eat spinach then you will get
stronger so this is just really a
rephrasing of the first one this is
really just putting it in if then form
you have your you have your if and
you're then but it's really saying the
same thing if you eat spinach that's the
same thing as eating the spinach then
you will become stronger then
you
will be stronger you get stronger so
this is saying the exact same thing i
will say that if we assume this first
statement is true then the second
statement is definitely true
now this third statement if you don't
eat spinach
then you will not get stronger
so this is interesting this is kind of
assuming that the only way to get
stronger is by eating spinach but that's
not what that first statement says
that's first statement says eating
spinach is a way to get you stronger so
if we think about ways to get stronger
there are there are other ways to get
stronger you could you could lift
weights
lift weights and maybe you don't want to
eat any any spinach at all maybe you eat
eggs
maybe you eat
eggs who knows there's a million you
know maybe you
you have a
drink milk who knows what there are a
lot of options that will that will get
you
stronger
drink milk so eating spinach is not the
only way so if you don't eat spinach you
still might be able to get stronger it's
not they're not ruling out that you
can't get stronger so i would say i
would not go with this statement right
over there let me do it in red so that i
can
mark it off this one is not necessarily
true you can get stronger other ways now
if you eat spinach you will definitely
get stronger if you believe that
statement but you can get stronger other
ways so just by not eating spinach if
you lift weights eat eggs who knows what
else you could still get stronger so
we'll rule out the second statement
now this third statement
you are not stronger
therefore you must not have eaten
spinach
now this is where we really have to put
our logician hats and a logician is just
someone who has really really really
good logic
you are not stronger therefore you must
not have eaten spinach and we have to be
very careful to separate our everyday
experience versus what we're trying to
deduce logically so in our everyday
experience i'm you know i i'm i i'm not
stronger but maybe i did maybe i did eat
spinach and and we'd say you know maybe
sometimes spinach doesn't make me
stronger etc etc but we have to remember
we're assuming this first statement is
true we're assuming this first statement
is absolutely true eating spinach makes
you stronger
if you had eaten spinach by definition
this first statement says you will be
stronger
if you are not stronger then there's no
way that you had ate some spinach so
this is actually true this is actually
true if we assume this first statement
is true
now this last statement you are stronger
therefore you must have eaten spinach
well this goes back to this idea we
didn't that first statement didn't say
spinach is the only way to get stronger
or the second statement was
it wasn't if and only if you eat spinach
then you will get stronger there's other
ways to get stronger you could lift
weights eat eggs drink milk so this last
statement you are stronger therefore you
have must have eaten spinach isn't
necessarily true you could have drank
lift lifted way to lift lifted weights
or ate eggs or anything like that so i
will rule this one out as well you
cannot make this conclusion given
given
given this first statement